شو ابرز الامراض اللي واجهتوها في
المعتقلين لا يوجد مرض مع هذا طبعا في
امراض كانت قاتله كتير اهم السلم
المرض اللي يعني اثار حيله الاطباء كتير
هو مرض الجرب يعني
واستفحاله داخل هذا
التهاب السحايا عاد عن امراض العاديه التي
تجي قريب
انفلونزا القمل
من اول السجن الى اخر السجنه
لم يستطيع سجناء التخلص من القمل موجود
دائما فصار امر عادي يعني وكان احيانا
يستخدمون ذلك ضدكم يعني
هنالك وكانها كانت يعني بسببكم انتم
دفع الرجال العسكريين يعني كان يؤتي ثماره
احيانا في موضوع جلب الادويه في حاله
الجرب
كيف حصل ذلك
نتيجه انه واقع واحد ظرف واحد عم يهتم
ابتكار الحلول واحده يعني دائما نعبر في
تواصل بين الرئيس المهجى وبين رئيس النوبه
مثلا تبع الحراسه والسجناء
فيعني هو يعقد صفقه معه
وهذا طبعا لم يتم الا بعد ما كان
فتح باب الزيارات ايضا من خلال الرشاوير
اللي هو مدير السجن
فصار عند السجناء هل يقومون برشوه مدير
السجون امه
من قريه جنب القرداحه
يدفعوا لها يعني مبلغ
راس الرئيس
بينما زياره للدكسوفه مثلا بغرفه او على
الشبك كانت تكلف اكثر بهالفتره هاي وقت
صار عندي المساجين مصاري نتيجه زيارات
يعني في بعض الناس كانت تبيع
بعض املاكه مشان تامن مبلغ محرز تعرف انه
ممكن هاي زياره ما بصير في غيرها يعني
ما كانوا يحتجوهم او ياخذوهم الاموال لا
على مستوى صغير
مشان جلب الادويه بيتم رشوه رئيس النوبه
او بسموه مساعد انضباط السجن